en eeuu donde la gente no está confinada
el kobe 19 sigue llenando las funerarias
y hay alarma pues la capacidad
hospitalaria está llegando al límite
este jueves el país batió otro triste
récord con casi 213 mil nuevos contagios
y un tercer día consecutivo pasando los
2500 fallecimientos
voltaire y aun ni es la realidad es que
diciembre enero y febrero van a ser
tiempos difíciles de hecho creo que van
a ser los momentos más difíciles en la
historia de la salud pública de esta
nación de estridentes nation ese mismo
jueves el presidente electo joe biden en
una entrevista con 100 en anunció que
durante los 100 primeros días de su
mandato impondría la mascarilla por otra
parte volvió a dar su confianza a
anthony fauci el asesor de la casa
blanca para el coronavirus criticado por
donald trump italia que fue el epicentro
de europeo de la crisis durante la
primera ola había levantado la cabeza
hasta ahora en las últimas 24 horas el
país ha confirmado 993 muertos a causa
del coronavirus
el peor dato registrado desde el
comienzo de la emergencia por la
pandemia en febrero según del ministerio
de sanidad
desde el 21 de diciembre hasta el 6 de
enero no se podrá viajar entre regiones
si quieres viajar a tu segunda casa no
puedes tengan cuidado el 25 de diciembre
el día de navidad el día de san esteban
el 26 de diciembre y el primero de enero
no se permitirá el movimiento entre
ciudades justamente de un común al otro
con estas medidas y toques de queda y
cierres de comercios los fines de semana
italia pretende que no se disparen los
números de muertes como en españa o
francia la buena noticia es que el país
ha logrado mantener hasta ahora la tasa
de contagio